más de 150 personas se reunieron en el
ministerio de cultura de cuba este
viernes para mostrar su solidaridad con
los artistas disidentes que se enfrentan
a la represión del estado lo que
queremos ver primero una garantía a
nuestras libertades la libertad que nos
escuchan nuestras demandas que tienen
que ver con vivir en cuba sin sentir
temor por como pensamos en hacer arte en
cuba sin que eso constituya un peligro
para seguir siendo antes hace unos diez
días varios disidentes iniciaron una
huelga de hambre para rechazar el
encarcelamiento del rapero de ni solís
este jueves las autoridades rompieron la
huelga y detuvieron a dos personas más a
raíz de esto nació la manifestación del
viernes que comenzó con dos docenas de
personas por la mañana y que fue
creciendo a lo largo del día incluyendo
a artistas de renombre internacional
como tania bruguera y fernando pérez
podemos decir que los manifestantes
exigieron un diálogo sobre los límites
de la libertad de expresión y lo que
llaman represión estatal los disidentes
lograron reunirse con representantes del
gobierno donde acordaron encuentros
periódicos para dialogar sobre sus
diferencias un logro histórico en un
país donde no se respeta el derecho a
manifestar y son pocas las veces que el
gobierno acepta un diálogo con su
contraparte